it used to be that if the government or
anyone else wanted to spy on you and
find out what you were thinking they'd
have to put in a bit of work to really
track everything governments needed a
real human spy to watch you
that meant that spying was a
labor-intensive job in heavily
surveilled countries like East Germany
where the government wanted to keep an
eye on everyone two out of every 13 East
Germans ended up being used by the Stasi
as an informant these days it's a lot
easier and takes fewer people to spy on
one person or spy on everyone for that
matter for that advance in mass
surveillance
you can thank modern technology you're
probably still safe from surveillance if
you're just writing or thinking or
talking on your own in your own house
but the moment you use the Internet to
save edit or share something things get
a lot simpler for the 21st century spy
you might have heard that sending an
email across the internet is like
sending a postcard unlike a sealed
envelope your message might be seen by a
few people on the way in fact the
majority of traffic on the Internet
emails phone calls photos video instant
messages is viewable by anyone who has
access to the computers that your
message passes through from the computer
in your home to your local ISP to the
final destination of your message and
all points between and on the Internet
there are a lot of points in between
whenever you visit a web site or save a
document or send a message online your
data goes through at least a handful of
computers and probably many more these
computers aren't owned by you or the
final recipient of the message but their
operators or someone who hacks into them
can look at and record everything about
your message including where it came
from and where it's meant to be going
some of these computers direct traffic
for thousands or millions of people so
if you can put the digital equivalent of
a spy camera in those computers you
could quickly collect the private
thoughts of an entire population there's
a way however to make your
communications private even as they
travel across the public
and that's by using strong encryption
encrypted messages are turned into a
form that is unreadable except to the
person at their destination since the Ed
Snowden revelations more and more
websites and internet companies have
been using encryption to protect data in
transit
but it's still not the default for many
Internet services to increase your own
use of encryption and to protect your
data you can use HTTPS Everywhere a
browser plug-in from the Electronic
Frontier Foundation that tells websites
you visit to use encryption when they
can the more people use encryption more
expensive it is to monitor everyone
which means that spies will have to go
back to targeted tailored surveillance
instead of trying to be a cheaper
version of East Germany Stasi spying on
everyone if you'd like to know more
about using encryption and HTTPS
Everywhere check out surveillance
self-defense from the Electronic
Frontier Foundation
you